in Avengers endgame that dusted heroes
arrives just in time to assist the
surviving Avengers in taking down Thanos
just as Captain America thought that I'd
have to go it alone
portals begin opening across the sky the
very first hero to step through is Black
Panther and we finally know why
Avengers ends game co-director Joe Russo
recently revealed during a reddit ask me
anything session that the king of
Wakanda wasn't technically the top
choice to return first
Sam Wilson aka Falcon was Joe and his
filmmaking brother Anthony Russo wanted
some to be the first person to
communicate with Captain America during
the battle with a nose since Sam was
fighting in Wakanda when he
disintegrated an Avengers infinity war
the directors knew that they needed to
have the wakandan portal be the first
one to open up after professor Hulk's
nap given that Sam isn't the most
important person in Wakanda the charla
wound up being the first hero to emerge
in endgame summons to hero who is heard
first telling captor his communications
device that the heroes are arriving to
his left the black panther is the first
one seen Russo added that we spent a lot
of time in the Edit room playing around
with a sequencing of the portals we
probably didn't lock that section of the
movie until about a month before the
film was in theaters we always wanted
Sam to be the first one to communicate
with capybaras comm and Sam was last in
Wakanda so logically the first portal
that would open would be the wakandan
portal the first person that would
logically walk through a portal from
Wakanda would be the king himself
bringing his army once again to the
defense of Captain the world
Joe added on the audio commentary track
included on the digital release of
Avengers endgame who else would you want
to have your back in this moment other
than to Charlie Roma Conda some that in
cap know that he's got someone coming in
on his left is also a reference to a fan
favorite moments in Captain America the
Winter Soldier in waste a star-spangled
Avenger keep slapping some on there run
don't say don't say he left come on in
the end the Black Panther being chosen
as the first hero to return after
Professor Hulk snap wasn't bound to some
big emotional reason it wasn't even due
to the Chara and Wakanda being some of
the Avengers most of loyal allies the
real explanation has a lot more to do
with logistics they wanted some to
communicate with cub first Sam was in
Wakanda when he was snapped away into
the ether and black panther is the king
of the nation so he showed up first
easy-breezy the issue of which hero
would return first offered a snap in
Avengers hands game wasn't the only
logistical issue the film's team had to
tackle end game co-writer stephen
mcfeely revealed on the endgame
commentary track that he and his writing
partner christopher markus wrote a
version of the script in which the
heroes came back and was shown
immediately just on an apt construction
level we were faced with a strange
problem where we needed to snaps of the
gauntlets and asked ourselves often what
does it mean to bring everybody back
we certainly tried a version where
everyone came back and you knew it
immediately and there they were doing
that prevented us from a really heroic
reveal and what a heroic reveal it wound
up being black panther entering
alongside sharee in a calle then giving
Captain America and knowing not as some
flies overhead we're getting chills just
thinking about it check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos by the MCU are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]